I think that the story of Simba is an a
typical and mythological story,
not only about the hero's journey,
but more importantly about the meaning
of growing up.
When Tim was born in the opening of the
film,
he is held up to look out over off
Africa's wildlife who bow down before
him,
freedom him with all respect and
obedience.
From a Freudian perspective,
this is a wonderful allegory for Freud's
concept of his majesty,
the baby.
When a child is born,
the first stage of his life is one of
infantile omnipotence,
vr.
At first it needs of knowing we are
special and the central focus of our
parents care and concern.
At this point,
we cannot see beyond our own needs in
the lion king,
Simba is not only the center of his
parents,
universe birth,
he is bound down before by the whole
assembled African wildlife.
Everything that like touches is our
kingdom.
A King's time is ruler rises and falls
like the sun.
One day Simba,
the Sun will set on my time here and
will rise with you as the new king.
Everything
this,
however it creates a problem.
Thanks to his father's rule.
The pride lands are imbalance.
Simba is this born in paradise and in
his infant they'll nip Athens.
He is the center of it.
Therefore,
there's nothing to prove himself,
nothing to conquer.
Hence his fascination with the elephants
grief yards.
Here,
he can defy parental authority and show
his bravery birth where his father's
bravery is a mature connection with the
danger and the possibility of death.
Simba in his infantile omnipotence has
no real connection to these things.
A suit characterize argues in the
Journal of child psychotherapy.
Adolescent risk taking is so often off
this nature.
It's a dare send out into the world to
show that we are immune to vulnerability
without any real emotional connection to
the dangerous.
We pretend to disdain
being brave.
It doesn't mean you go looking for
trouble.
You're not scared of anything
I was today.
Yes,
I thought I might lose you.
Of course this cannot last and to
reality of danger and death is trusted
in December's life in a haunting way
when Mufasa dies while trying to save
Simba due to a plot by my father's
brother's car is from a rational
perspective,
rather unclear why Simba feel so guilty
about his father's death.
He listened to scar wader.
It's where it was still so wait for his
father and he didn't cost the stampede.
So one argument is that felt unworthy of
being saved and worthy of his father's
sacrifice.
Well,
Fossa seems to rue flawlessly.
He is a constant reminder of what Simba
is not brave,
strong and wise after symbols,
filter tend to prove himself worthy in
the elephants' graveyard it's facing
now.
He knows his arrogance and infantile
omnipotence fades away and he feels
unworthy both of his father,
his sacrifice and his destiny off being
king,
so he runs
run away.
Another key argument for skills is
Freudian oedipal teary,
where fruit argues to wish of songs to
replace and take the positions of the
father's dad.
You shouldn't.
In the beginning of the film.
Timber in this arrogance,
Singh's office wished to become king.
This of course implies determining his
father or his father dying as was also
realized by on the strader's when the
parody to song
hello.
Hi.
Simba is either consciously or
unconsciously aware of his wish to
replace his father,
which feeds his feelings of guilt for
his father's death.
Therefore,
in an attempt to escape his guilt,
he runs away from his father's position
as king.
He this rinse away,
but it's not only from the private lands
and it's right for places king,
but also from all the personality traits
his father embodied.
Yeah,
got to put your past behind.
You look at bad things happen and you
can't do anything about it.
Right,
right,
wrong.
When the world turns its back on you,
you turn your back on Delaware.
It is here that Simba anthers and
adolescent phase where he chooses
escapism in pleasure,
discarding any responsibility he joins a
gang or fourth categorized describes as
a sexual dropouts where the prevailing
wisdom is not to worry about any
consequences of one's actions.
Dan,
a problem three
this way.
Similar defense himself from his guilt
by cutting himself off from the past and
immersing himself in living in the
moment.
It's quite telling that in this sequence
Simba turns to eating bugs and just
having his Neil's faults by [inaudible]
where Simba first envied his father
strength,
power and aggression and tried to
emulate those traits,
no fuels,
these traits and his rivalry with his
father were responsible for his father's
death.
Therefore he relinquishes his
competitiveness,
healthy aggression and ambition in fear
that he cannot control these traits and
we'll become destructive.
Simba at this point is not aware that
giving up these traits has a cost as
well and that it is not the solution.
If we give up our ambition,
competitiveness and aggression for
escape pleasure,
we cannot develop ourselves fully and
take our place in the world in an
escapist position,
we will remain self centered and enabled
to help those around us.
Eventually both our own lives and our
surroundings,
we all start falling apart as Jordan
Peterson states.
You know,
we have this strange idea that's
especially again foisted on young men
that the pathway to virtue is through
weakness and harmlessness and that's
just simply not true that that that's
the pathway to uselessness and
resentment.
Cimbar realizes this when Nala confronts
him to,
to symbolic,
opting out of responsibility,
the pride lands have fallen into ruin
and all animals are suffering.
Look,
sometimes bad things happens and there's
nothing you can do about it.
So why worry?
Because it's your responsibility.
Tim Bias to tear himself away from the
escapists pleasures off his Hakuna
Matata philosophy in order to take a
mature place in a world where he can be
responsible for himself and others to do
this.
However,
he must complete a difficult task or
facing himself and his guilt of his
father's death.
You said you'd always be there for me.
That's true or not.
It's because of me.
It's my fault.
It's life
as client stays.
The oedipal struggle is to relinquish
one's wish to take the fall dish
replace,
but instead of taking one's own place in
the world while still adopting was good
in a father too.
Happy to be both like him and different
than him instead of needing to be in in
the lion king.
This is symbolized beautifully by
visualizing symbols,
internal struggle through him finding
his rate through tick tones and then
seeing himself and his father in his
reflection in the water
you see
he needs.
I think this is the key moment of Simba
story,
the painful journey or facing himself
and his guilt about his father is what
enables Simba to transcend this
adolescence and become a man or in this
case lion in his own rights.
Simba understands that he is not as far
though that he can find his father
within him only by internalizing Mufasa
and the qualities here,
narratives from him,
Simba can adopt responsibility for
others and face scar in order to restore
the pride lands to balance.
And the end to center architect Malesan
lesson off the lion king is that in
order to grow up we must adopt
responsibility of ourselves and others.
If we choose to escape its pleasures and
renounce our healthy aggression,
our competitiveness and ambition,
we've become unable to engage
productively in the world.
To remember that who we are is to
remember where we can be.
It is to adopt the responsibility or
realizing our full potential and to try
to make our world a better place.
All right.
Thank you everyone for watching.
It's been a while but it's good to be
back.
If should like our work,
consider supporting us on Patrion.
We offer some awesome rewards and it
helps us sustain his channel.
Also a big thank you to the following
top patrons.
Uh,
your help is really appreciate it and
thank you to everyone.
We will see you for the next video.